warum gibt es in unserem universum mehr
materie als antimaterie diese frage ist
eines der größten rätsel der physik und
könnte bald möglicherweise gelöst werden
denn das neue experiment am cern ist im
wahrsten sinne des wortes ein eiskalter
durchbruch mit einer speziellen
laserkühlung wurden hier antimaterie
atome auf temperaturen nahe dem
absoluten nullpunkt abgekühlt kommen wir
so also endlich den grundfragen der
physik auf die spur
klicks um science and future hier gibt
es drei mal pro woche spannendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr herzlich
willkommen materie und antimaterie
fachleute sind überzeugt davon dass
beide kurz nach dem urknall vor etwa
13,8 milliarden jahren entstanden sind
und das quasi zu gleichen teilen
heute dagegen existiert ein krasses
ungleichgewicht und die materie
überwiegt ansonsten würde unsere welt
die so ziemlich ausschließlich aus
materie besteht gar nicht existieren
klar ist also die rätsel rund um das
ungleichgewicht von materie und
antimaterie im universum sind groß und
die rätsels lösung ist gleichzeitig auch
die voraussetzung für unsere existenz
fachleute weltweit setzen deswegen viel
hoffnung auf experimente in diesem
kontext auch die alpha kollaboration am
cern hat die antimaterie ganz genau im
visier
und das mit erfolg denn jetzt vermelden
die forschungsteams einen durchbruch im
renommierten fachmagazin nature
berichtet ein cern forschungsteam jetzt
dass die anti wasserstoff mit hilfe von
laser gekühlt haben eine echte premiere
und die hoffnung ist nun groß endlich
auch zu verstehen wie sich antimaterie
verhält dazu später mehr
schon seit knapp 90 jahren wissen wir
dass jedes teilchen einen partner hat
ein antiteilchen quasi doch wenn wir
weit zurückschauen wird nicht nur
deutlich wie wenig wir bisher über
materie und antimaterie wissen sondern
auch wie wichtig das zusammenspiel von
materie und antimaterie ist denn beim
urknall entstand den heutigen
vorstellungen zufolge genauso viel
antimaterie wie die uns bekannte materie
alle diese teilchen im jungen kosmos
prallten auf entgegengesetzten pol
anti-teilchen doch warum haben sich dann
antimaterie und materie nicht sofort
wieder vernichtet so wie es doch
eigentlich immer der fall ist wenn
antiteilchen und teilchen aufeinander
treffen
die antwort darauf kennen wir bis heute
nicht doch klar ist das ganze war wohl
eine art kosmische fügung denn aus den
übrig gebliebenen bruchteil bildeten
sich im lauf von milliarden jahren
sterne planeten galaxien und später dann
eben auch wir menschen astronomie teams
weltweit gehen davon aus dass ein
subtiler unterschied zwischen materie
und antimaterie dafür gesorgt hat dass
ein teil der materie überlebt hat doch
wohin genau liegt der unterschied warum
gibt es dieses ungleichgewicht im
universum warum bestehen planeten sterne
und menschen fast ausschließlich aus
materie und warum ist die antimaterie
dagegen sollte ein exot welche
subatomaren prozesse im urknall haben
etwas mehr materie als antimaterie
vorgebracht fragen über fragen auf die
wir bis heute keine endgültige antworten
müssen
möglicherweise könnte ein gewisser
effekt der etwas mit symmetrie zu tun
hat die antwort sein ein mechanismus der
symmetrie verletzung schon seit längerer
zeit wird also vermutet naturgesetze
behandeln materie und antimaterie nicht
gleichwertig experimente mit antimaterie
können helfen diese zahlreichen rätsel
zu lösen doch das stellt die fachwelt
vor eine große herausforderung denn
versuche mit antimaterie sind super
aufwendig und kostspielig kein wunder
denn antimaterie bleibt nur für eine
kurze zeit stabil und das eben auch nur
in bestimmten magnet fallen die meisten
experimente erfordern zudem auch dass
die antimaterie extrem heruntergekühlt
wird da die anti atome sich dann wenig
bewegen hier gilt der grundsatz je
wärmer ein gas desto schneller bewegen
sich die atome darin zufällig hin und
her
dazu der wissenschaftler jeffrey hangst
deren der alpha kollaboration am cern
beteiligt ist die erzeugung von
antiwasserstoff mit dem
geringstmöglichen kinetischen energie
ist daher ein wichtiges ziel schon seit
rund zehn jahren beschäftigen
forschungsteams am cern sich mit atomen
aus antiwasserstoff diese bestehen aus
einem antiproton im kern und einem
positron in einer atom würde das
positron ist dabei übrigens das anti
teilchen des elektrons und tatsächlich
konnten die fachleute hier schon einige
folge vermelden beispielsweise gelang es
antiwasserstoff atome in einer
magnetischen falle zu halten und dort
genauer zu analysieren doch auch hier
wieder das problem die teilchen bewegen
sich einfach viel zu schnell und
detailliert untersucht werden zu können
sowohl die bislang vor allem das
verfahren der laserkühlung eingesetzt um
die temperaturen von gasen abzukühlen
und so im endeffekt auch die mittlere
geschwindigkeit der teilchen zu senken
doch das geht bislang eben nur bei
gewöhnlichen atom und eben nicht bei
antimaterie
doch dem forschungsteam der alpha
kollaboration ist hier jetzt ein
entscheidender durchbruch gelungen
denn sie haben ist tatsächlich geschafft
die antiwasserstoff atome mit hilfe von
laserkühlung deutlich herunter zu kühlen
dabei wird die eigenbewegung der atome
abgebremst und zwar durch den einsatz
von laserstrahlen hierbei ist es wichtig
dass sowohl die frequenz als auch die
richtung des lesers stimmen denn dann
können die photonen die eigene bewegung
der atome tatsächlich abbremsen
so gelang es im experiment tatsächlich
die antiwasserstoff atome bis knapp über
dem nullpunkt herunterzukühlen
dabei standen diese dann fast still das
team nutzte dafür den sogenannten
dopplereffekt ein grundlegendes prinzip
der physik habt ihr vielleicht auch
schon mal gehört die fachleute
vergleichen dieses phänomen mit der
sirene eines krankenwagens der ton wird
deutlich höher wenn sich der
rettungswagen in unserer direkten nähe
befindet der grund dafür liegt darin
dass der schall gestaucht wird wenn der
krankenwagen mitsamt sirene wegfährt
klingt das sirenen heulen für unsere
ohren tiefer bei schneller fahrt schiebt
der krankenwagen die schallwellen
vorsicht zusammen denn er fährt ja quasi
in sie hinein
die schallwellen hinter den wagen
dagegen ziele auseinander und die
frequenz wird kleiner
genau das bezeichnet man als blog live
aid ich war als ich weiß alles ein
bisschen kompliziert deswegen hier
nochmal kurz zusammengefasst wenn sich
eine schall oder lichtquelle auf uns
zubewegt erreichen uns höhere frequenzen
wenn sich die quelle von uns weg bewegt
da müssen wir niedrigere frequenzen bei
dem aktuellen experiment der alpha
kollaboration war zudem auch noch
entscheidend dass die atome das
laserlicht nur bei bestimmten frequenzen
absorbieren können
heißt also auch erst dann funktioniert
diese art der kühlmethoden doch wie
genau kommt es sind jetzt dazu dass die
atome durch den laserstrahl abgebremst
werden sobald sich die atome auf den
laserstrahl zu bewegen verschiebt sich
für sie die eingestrahlte frequenz
stichwort dopplereffekt einzelne atome
im gas dem plötzlichen der lage das
licht zu absorbieren
doch dabei bekommen sie einen kleinen
rückstoß begründet durch die impuls
erhaltung wenn sie dann wieder ein licht
quandt mit derselben frequenz aussenden
bekommen sie erneut einen rückstoß dabei
ist es also so dass die photonen von den
teilchen immer nur aus ein und derselben
richtung absorbiert werden
das aussenden allerdings geschieht in
alle möglichen richtungen und so werden
die atome im mittel gesehen abgebremst
dieses verfahren wurde so also erst mal
ich jetzt auch für antimaterie
eingesetzt und zwar erfolgreich
die antiwasserstoff atome die mit einem
lichtteilchen eines passend
eingestellten ultravioletten lakers
getroffen wurden wurden um jeweils rund
zwölf kilometer pro stunde abgebremst
wenn mehrere solcher treffer gelangen
dann hatte sich die geschwindigkeit des
anti wasserstoffatoms noch weiter
reduziert insgesamt wurden bei dem
aktuellen experiment 1000
antiwasserstoff atome in der alpha 2
anlage am cern erzeugt diese wurden dann
von einem gepulsten laserstrahl von
etwas mehr als 100 21,6 nanometer
wellenlänge beschossen
das forschungsteam selbst stellt fest
dass diese antimaterie laserkühlung
bislang weniger effektives als sie ihr
gegenstück für normale atome doch die
pläne der fachleute sind sehr groß sie
wollen die alte anlage so schnell wie
möglich so umbauen dass sie somit in der
lage sind den anti wasserstoff noch
weiter herunterzukühlen
die fachwelt ist ziemlich überrascht
über diesen erfolg und hat große
hoffnung mit hilfe dieser kühl methode
von antiwasserstoff spannende neue
versuche mit antimaterie zu ermöglichen
alle experimente die bislang mit
normalem wasserstoff durchgeführt wurden
könnten somit dann auch mit anti
wasserstoff durchgeführt werden
auch die frage ob antiwasserstoff der
gravitation genauso unterliegt wie
normale materie könnte so möglicherweise
geklärt werden und hier könnte uns
möglicherweise wirklich spannende
erkenntnisse erwarten denn wenn hier
diskrepanz
offenbart würden wäre dies tatsächlich
ein hinweis auf eine ganz neue
physikalische gesetzmäßigkeit wenn schon
einstein hatte in seiner
relativitätstheorie eigentlich gesagt
das ist hier keine unterschiede geben
dürfte
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam die
demonstration der laserkühlung für
antimaterie hat sowohl unmittelbare als
auch weitreichende bedeutung die
fähigkeit die bewegung von antimaterie
atom mit laserlicht zu kontrollieren
kann bahnbrechende möglichkeiten für
künftige experimente wie anti-atom
fontänen die anti atom interferometrie
oder die erzeugung von antimaterie
molekülen schaffen
super spannend also was sich da gerade
in der physikalischen welt tut apropos
ganz neue physik schaut doch gerne auch
mal auf meinem youtube channel four bei
astro comics tv und helfen mir mein ziel
von 60.000 abos zu erreichen also würde
mich total freuen
in meinem neuen video erfahrt ihr noch
mehr über eine ganz neue physik die die
wissenschaftliche welt gerade ziemlich
in aufruhr versetzt es sieht nämlich so
aus als würden wir unsere welt bislang
überhaupt noch gar nicht richtig
verstehen
ansonsten freue ich mich auf euch hier
im nächsten video über klicks um science
and future bis dann bleibt dran